- What did you think of?
'Cause you were a model,
so I'm just asking, what did you think?
- Very, very good.
Very good.
- Yes, so creative!
- It's so creative and it's not easy,
especially now in the
days of Instagramming
and things like that.
I enlist my husband to
do it a lot of the times.
I had a background in modeling.
Actually before I started
acting, I modeled.
I was actually in Japan,
I was doing an ad for Sony of all things.
And I had a monkey that I
was working with that day.
His name was Dodo-chan.
I'll never forget that name,
I promise.
(laughter)
And he was really, really sweet,
running all over the place
and posing with me and on me.
And then, we had our lunch break.
And then, Dodo-chan saw--
- Like a spider monkey?
- Yeah, like a spider monkey.
He was exactly, a little spider monkey.
Don't be fooled by how cute they are.
- Yeah, and so am I, girl.
- There was this big bowl
of fruit and everybody watched
as Dodo-chan just saw that bowl of fruit
and just dove into the
passion fruit and the kiwi
and all of them were like, "Oh, my god.
"He loves the fruit, it's so great!"
And they were like, "All
right, everybody back to work."
(groans)
And Dodo-chan decided
he wanted to pose on top of my head
and we thought that was super cute.
- I know where this is going.
- Until,
you see there where this is going.
Dodo-chan just completely
relieved himself.
(horrified groans)
(laughs)
- Please, tell me the photo is somewhere!
- Let me tell you what.
I'd gone back to Japan the following year.
And there on the subway,
were the ads of me.
And I remember looking at it,
'cause it was such a
(laughs) horrific day.
But you wouldn't tell, I looked so happy
with Dodo-chan
(laughter)
sitting on my shoulder
and I was like this.
And little did anybody know.
- Well, you've gotten
really close.
- We got really, really close.
So, yes.
- It's a different level of relationship
at that point.
(laughs)